simple linear regression versus multiple
linear regression the simple linear
regression uses only one independent
variable to infer or predict the
dependent variable for example do the
weekly working hours have an influence
on the hourly salary of employees in a
multiple linear regression several
independent variables are used to infer
or predict the dependent variable for
example do the weekly working hours and
the age of employees have an influence
on their hourly salary so therefore the
difference between a simple linear
regression and the multiple linear
regression is that in one case only one
independent variable is used and in the
other case we use several independent
variables of course you can also
calculate your regression online just
visit datatap.net copy your data into
the table and select the variables that
simple